متى يجتمع الرئيس التركي بنظيره السوري
سؤال باتت اجابته تقترب اكثر من اي وقت
ففي مسارى خريطه الاتصال بين انقره ودمشق
يبدو ان القطار التطبيع ماض في سكته وهي
خريطه طريق ترتكز على عده محطات
الاسبوع الماضي شهد لقاءا غير مسبوق منذ
11 عاما يجسد خطوات مهمه في التقارب
التركي السوري فبعد لقاء وزراء دفاع تركيا
وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو بمشاركه قاده
اجهزه الاستخبارات كشف وزير الخارجيه
التركي عن اجتماعا مع نظيره السوري
والروسي منتصف يناير الحالي مشيرا الى انه
قد يعقد في بلد اخر تقارب متسارع وتفاصيل
تتكشف عن اللقاء الثلاثي الاخير فتركيه
وافقت على الانسحاب الكامل من الاراضي في
الشمال السوري واكدت على احترامها وحده
وسلامه الاراضي السوريه في الاجتماع ايضا
عن قرا اكدت انها لم تعد ت وباللاجئين
السوريين فعودتهم كانت على راس الملفات
اجتماع موسكو بحث ايضا وفق مسؤول تركي
لرويترز امن الحدود والعمل المشترك بين
انقره ودمشق لمواجهه ومكافحه ما وصفه
المسؤول بالارهاب الذي تمثله قصد وداعش
وباقي التنظيمات صحيفه الوطن السوريه
المقربه من النظام اكدت نقلا عن مسؤولين
سوريين ان الاطراف اتفقت على اعتبار حزب
العمال الكردستاني مليشيا عميله للولايات
المتحده واسرائيل وتشكل خطرا على سوريا
وتركيا
تفاهمات القت بظلالها على شمال سوريا حيث
رفض المسؤولون الاكراد المحليون مخرجات
لقاء موسكو الثلاثي وعوده النظام ممددين
بما اعتبروه منحى الشرعيه للنظام